hey guys welcome to another moneymaking
guide uh today I'm going to be showing
you how to make up to 850k an hour and
up to 140k Magic experience and now I'm
going to be going over three different
methods uh that you can train your magic
they're all going to be in the lunar
spell book so be aware and yeah they're
all very profitable methods and do give
you a good amount of magic experience as
well all right let's get started okay
guys so the three methods I'm going to
be going over today are all on the lunar
spell book uh so be prepared you will
need to do uh lunar diplomacy and dream
Mentor for uh I guess a couple of these
uh so this is going to have some pretty
high requirements but uh it is worth it
if you can get it uh so I'm going to be
going over the humidify spell uh which
is pretty good GP per hour uh very click
intensive in mediocre magic experience
I'm going to be going over the plank
make spell which is a little more
unknown is actually really good uh Magic
experience per hour and uh it is
profitable not nearly as much so uh and
the tan leather spell probably the best
one of them all uh pretty reasonable
magic experience over 100k an hour as
well as really good money per hour you
can get upwards of a mil uh per hour
sometimes by using uh this method but of
course it does have the caveat that you
need to have completed the um hard fiic
Diaries which is a much higher
requirement uh so that's why I'm kind of
presenting all these different three
methods cuz more than likely if you've
completed lunar diplomacy you should be
able to do at least one of these and
yeah so let's get started okay so first
out I'm going to check out the humidify
spell uh so I've just bought
1,000 uh clay and I guess 40 astal runes
I need uh to humidify it all this seems
to be the most profitable way to train
using this spell now the thing that is
good about this spell is it doesn't have
a very uh High requirement as far as the
lunar spells go you will need to do
dream Mentor but it doesn't require a
diary and I think it's only
78 or so it only has a requirement of
level 68 so not a huge magic level
relative to the lunar spell book I mean
um so yeah let's go ahead and deposit
our coins we had
91k and we're going to need some water
runes as well for this if you have a
steam battle stuff that will be ideal
but yeah basically just draw the clay
and then you're going to click on
humidify spell it has about a 2 or 3
second delay and then you got to go back
and Bank it all so unfortunately since
it does all of it at once this is a
pretty click intensive method because
you have to go into the bank click
withdraw go back and uh do this as
quickly as possible I could probably set
up some placeholders which would help
out a bit here uh but again there's not
too much you can do but it's going to be
slow no matter what so we should be
getting roughly uh 40 to 50K experience
an hour uh depending on how quickly I
can click and yeah we'll do the 1,000
and see how much it is okay so I just
finished up with the 1,000 Clays now one
thing I noted is that um having read the
wiki and then trying it myself uh the XP
rates are based on high efficiency
that's using Bank fillers using your F1
and F2 Keys uh and really focusing uh
what I was doing is just literally
depositing withdrawing and I got about
30k XP per hour and about uh about 15K I
could probably humidify per hour so
let's go ahead and just sell off the
1,000 clay and uh sold them off perfect
so we sold them for 132k and we bought
everything for about 100K okay so we
made about 33k and this took me about 4
minutes and so that's about 8.25k a
minute time 60 is about 500k you could
get upwards of 700 800k an hour if
you're playing play at a higher
efficiency than I was so reasonably good
profit per hour the experience is not
that great though and is very click
intensive I would really recommend this
mainly if you have lunar diplomacy done
and your magic level is only around 70
all right so the next method is going to
be casting plank make now you will need
level 86 magic for this I'm going to be
using a magic potion to boost me up uh
just so I can show you guys uh you will
also need the dream enter Quest on top
top of the lunar diplomacy Quest done
but uh having tested this out this is
actually one of my more favorite methods
uh it is Click intensive but not nearly
as much as the rest of them so we bought
100 mahogany logs as runes and nature
runes so we'll claim those uh so using
the plank make spell is a lot more like
enchanting jewelry all you going to do
is click on the log and go back and I
repeat it's click intensive yes but less
so I my personal opinion than uh the uh
ify spell cuz that requires a lot of
clicking into the bank and not this is
more just like enchanting and this a
little more chill uh the benefit here is
the magic experience per hour is
extremely high uh the gold per hour
isn't as good um but you will definitely
want to be um using this on mahogany
planks this is the only way you're going
to break even or profit is from these
logs none of the other ones are
profitable so I would recommend only
doing mahogany planks uh another fairly
large benefit to uh this method is it's
not inhibited by a buying limit you may
have noticed that uh the humidify spell
um used well you could do up to 22,000
in an hour uh so theoretically if you're
going to train this for multiple hours
you would hit the bind limit on the
grand exchange and not be able to buy
more that's not an issue with mahogany
logs cuz you can only do about uh, 1500
to 2,000 an hour and the buy limits uh
10,000 so you'll never hit it so that is
another benefit uh to this method so
let's go ahead I'll do this for well 100
planks and see what we're at okay so I
finished uh casting the plank Mak spell
uh for The 100 cast and I was roughly
getting 150k experience per hour which I
think is pretty reasonable to expect uh
you get up to 160 if you are really
paying attention uh but 150 is pretty
easy to get uh so we'll go ahead and
just sell off these mahogany logs keep
in mind I'm not waiting for the best
price or anything I'm just kind of
instant selling them and I look like
we're going to profit uh 11k which is
not a lot but the amount of experience
we got is uh so uh well let's say 12K
okay so 12K uh divided by 100 so 120
coins per Plank and I was able to get
about 1,700 uh per hour uh so it's about
200k which is actually not that bad
considering you're getting 160k uh Magic
experience that is profitable so this is
actually my preferred method to train
magic currently uh because really good
magic experience and profitable uh and
yes so let's move on to the last method
and uh last up is going to be the tan
leather spell which is by far the best
money per hour uh as well as giving
pretty decent XP per hour it's not
actually as good as a plank make spell
but it is worth it because you're
getting like 5 600 700k more an hour uh
with this you can get up to a m an hour
but more likely it'll be around 8 00k to
900k Mark um the problem here is that
you need the um frck hard Diaries which
is a fairly High requirement uh not
unobtainable but it is much of a higher
requirement than the other two methods
uh you'll need 78 magic for this uh if
that's also an issue I wouldn't do this
one so unfortunately I don't actually
have the requirement yet I'm very close
uh but I was in the process of making
this video and I couldn't really make a
kind of lunar spell uh related video
without including this to some degree uh
so I decided to toss it there anyway I
hope you guys understand so what I've
bought is 100 cast of the tan leather
spell uh which is going to give uh 500
Green Dragon hide um so one other thing
worth noting is once again there is a
buying limit restriction here uh 10,000
every 4 hours is the buying limit and
you can do about 7,500 an hour uh I'm
going to say about 6,000 for my uh my
clicking speed uh but either way let's
go ahead and convert these and I'll see
how much uh we made oh okay there we go
guys uh so we converted them to uh Green
Dragon leather theoretically uh so what
I ended up selling them for was 1883 so
it looks like uh you'd profit about
57k off of um well took a 5 minutes in
theory so 57 times uh 5 minutes will be
12 would give us about 684k an hour uh
probably up to 800k now I've asked a
couple people and it is about
130k to 140k an hour
uh Magic experience so this method is by
far the most profitable and um XP wise
the best your best option the only
reason I would not recommend it is just
because of the higher requirement as
well as the uh buying limit on the GE
that being said you could go ahead and
buy different Dragon leather uh so you
could go buy let's say I don't know
10,000 Green Dragon leather 10,000 blue
dragon leather and 10,000 black dragon
leather let's say something like that
and then you wouldn't really be hitting
the buy and limit uh but they would have
different profits associated with them
so you'd have to make that decision uh
based on the margins all right guys
that's it so those are the three methods
that I've discovered that can give you a
decent profit while actually giving you
really good magic experience per hour
because normally when you're getting
like over 100k magic experience per hour
it's going to be costing you money so
the lunner spell book is very handy uh
for that as for those of you looking to
profit and train your magic I hope the
methods serve you well all right hope
you guys enjoyed the video and I will
see you guys next time
[Music]